so I need you to be a huge favor I just
need you to be real and a reason why a
lot of y'all don't want to be real cuz
some of you would rather be in a lie and
at least have a lie than not have
anything at
all you already know the reality about
that
relationship you already know that job
you ain't about to your boss ain't about
to cash you out you just scared to quit
and start your own business CU you don't
know if you're going to do well or not
you know you shouldn't come on be honest
you know you still shouldn't be at that
job right now let me see your hand let's
just be real let me see the hand you
know you shouldn't still raise it high
don't play with me raise say h you still
shouldn't be at that job but you're
delusional that one day is going to be
your day that one day you going to merge
your job and your getting your calling
together it's not going to happen you
gonna have to just leave